all right it is here star wars episode 8
the last Jedi is upon us let's get our
nerd on Star Wars Episode eight the last
Jedi so Star Wars the last Jedi is
written and directed by Rian Johnson
this is the eighth installment of the
numbered Star Wars movies not counting
the spin-offs in the road 1 so in the
force awakens star killer base was
destroyed kylo Ren goes back to snow ray
finds Luke Skywalker hands him his dad's
lightsaber and/or his lightsaber and
that's where we start out so ray wants
to be trained by Luke kylo Ren has
something to prove and all of the while
poe dameron and the rest of the
resistance wants to be the spark that
will light the fire till it burn the
first order down and like any movie
there are things I like things I didn't
like because it's just a movie first of
all what I like let's talk about Luke
Skywalker Mark Hamill zero lines in the
last movie this is kind of a long time
coming I thought he was great in this
movie he's clearly a damaged man the
weight of the world which is funny
because it's not just one world and star
wars so I guess it would be the way to
the galaxy is on his shoulders and you
really feel it he's kind of an Old Crow
much and he's kind of a dick it's kind
of sarcastic but I thought he was
fantastic in fact my favorite of the
arcs in this movie is race time on the
island with Luke
it was great is as gruff and grumpy as
Luke was he didn't cease to be Luke
it could have been Mark Hamill just
being an old grumpy guy and for a second
I thought he was so then something
happens he has some dialogue we're like
oh no you're still Luke Skywalker you've
just kind of been raked through a river
of [ __ ] but Luke is still there that's
important also Poe Dameron has a lot
more to do I'm glad Poe Dameron had a
lot more to do of our new heroes he's
the one we saw the least in the last
movie I'm glad we saw a bit more of him
in this movie we saw a lot more of him
actually there were a couple things that
moved it straight of reminded me of
Battlestar Galactica's like Rian Johnson
was like oh I love Battlestar Galactica
I'm gonna put that in a Star Wars movie
that sounds awesome right because they
weren't they were cool and I will say
this about the movie when a character is
in danger you do feel that danger I love
that how many movies out there the
characters in peril you're like yeah
whatever I know they're fine there's
something about the craftsmanship in
this one Rian Johnson was like this is
how you should make a movie like there's
that feeling of security is gone so few
times does it happen in a film which the
movie has a lot of humor in it too
there's no thing quite a few times the
last time the human didn't land as much
as they probably wanted it to point is
if that JJ Abrams humor irritated you in
episode 7 it's still in episode 8 so
probably irritate
and visually speaking Ryan Johnson is on
another level of directors less lens
flares I could say that the action
sequences are great just space battles
look fantastic the ground battles look
fantastic the movie just looks beautiful
there is one scene in this movie in
particular that it's just it's such an
orgasmically gorgeous moment it happens
and it's there and you're watching it
you're like I want that poster or
screensaver or wallpaper on the phone
another scene I'm talking about the
movie will go on you'll be like is that
that and then it'll happen a bit like
that's exactly what he's talking about
the Finan what's her name rose i think
her name's rose finn and rose that arc
is the one room like and it just didn't
really work for me this is actually it's
the arc i can talk about that's not a
spoiler and the fact that it's not a
spoiler the fact that i feel like i can
talk about their arc but i don't feel
like i can talk about a lot of the other
arc shows how just insignificant their
arc is they go to a dump planet that
bores me and just when they're on their
mission rest assured you can leave the
theater to take a piss you're welcome
internet i mean it has a lesson behind
it and that is animal cruelty is bad i
have an animal lover right I'm there for
the message I smell like did you bring
them to that planet to have that message
in a Star Wars movie because it really
does detract from the movie as a whole
it's clearly when the movie bogs down
I've seen a couple of people on Twitter
say the movie feels too long it's that
scene if you take that out you could
shave off a half an hour off this movie
I mean when it got to that that was cool
for him but that then brings me to
phasma who is in this movie and it's not
like it's some big comebacks not like
they were like oh we didn't really use
phasma in the last movie now here's her
chance to shine that's like we didn't
use her in the last movie and she's just
as useless here's the bum phasma
underwhelmed me snoke underwhelmed me
yeah the big super baddie that was built
up in the first movie now we're gonna
see more room here the movie and I mean
this in the most complimentary way goes
in bold new direction unexpected
directions things that Star Wars really
hasn't done and when you do bold
directions in Star Wars with established
lore that nerds like me can kind of
quantify sometimes you like mr. Spock
fascinating sometimes you're like han
Solo that's not how the force works
narrative Lee speaking I cannot think of
another Star Wars movie taking the same
flight path proverbial flight path the
last Jedi Tech there are some things I
love about that and there are some
things I just didn't like and that's why
this movie's definitely one of those
movies it's like you might you're gonna
have to watch this twice and I really
want to watch this movie again so I can
really see if the flaw
still stick with me if I forgive them
time fades everything time fades
greatness and time fades flaws all
depends on which side of history and
movies on guys in the end the last Jedi
is admittedly complex but there are a
couple things in this movie that leave
you feeling unfulfilled Luke was great
Rey was great kylo Ren really everyone
who was great in the first movie they're
also great here but I like about the
movie is his deeper tones and its themes
and the message about heroes and people
in general I really like that definitely
enjoyable it's positive you should go
see it this movie has moments of
greatness like character moments that
I'm going to remember this movie also
has judgment calls that leave me feeling
underwhelmed and unfulfilled and it's
all about how much the frustrating
things frustrate you did they frustrate
you as much as they frustrated me I'm
gonna do the responsible thing here as I
feel this movie is a two time wash
before I write it up not giving a rating
yet because giving a rating ultimately
would be unfair to both of us this is
why this review was so [ __ ] vague
that if I give a rating now for you guys
you'll be like you gave that rating but
you didn't give a good reason as to why
I got that rating the things you love
the things you hated where it why does
it stand there so you'll feel cheated
and unfulfilled I just think in a world
where YouTube's like a ruins got to get
it up now did you see your feet at 9
a.m. this morning 9 a.m. Tuesday morning
yeah that [ __ ] went [ __ ] bananas
because we all of us YouTube people like
we got to get the reviews up right when
the embargo lifts so we all do it at the
same time we all have to mad scramble I
feel like I haven't processed this movie
enough to actually write it up so I feel
like the responsible thing to do we just
hold off on the writing let you know how
I view the movie on my initial
run-through that's done yes here we are
neither of us benefit from a rating
today so if I'm going to write this
movie I will write it in my spoiler
video which I will upload this weekend
after I watch the movie again so star
wars the last Jedi have you seen it what
did you think about it or have you not
what are you looking forward to whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]